c'est vrai que vous avez disparu à un
moment est ce que c'est le moindre
succès vous ne vouliez pas vous étiez
passé à autre chose on vire les disparus
maintenant je pas disparu moi je
quelqu'un de très honnête et et j'ai en
fait les gens qui me connaissent
personnellement me disent mais tu n'as
rien à voir avec ce métier le seul truc
qui te tient dans ce métier c'est de
chanter mais sinon je je suis pas les
codes je suis j'ai jamais écouter ce
qu'on m'a dit on m'a dit vas sur les
plateaux télé surtout ne dis pas ça ne
parle pas comme ça ne te comporte pas
comme ça je fais tout l'inversé de ce
qu'on dit et est en fait moi j'ai arrêté
parce que je me sentais plus du tout
sincère plus du tout investi
donc je me suis dit j'ai pas envie de
devenir comme certaines personnes que
j'ai pu rencontrer je ne veux pas
devenir ça je veux rester qui je suis et
je m'écarte et j'étais jeune j'avais 22
23 ans quand j'ai eu dès le début on a
essayé de vous marquer tu es c'est à
dire quand vous aviez oui 19 ans a été
dévoré par un essai de mais bien la rue
qui est une image avait bien sûr on a
essayé mais ils ont jamais réussi on
fait donc des ses skis les ans vers des
puits et je suis pas parti parce que
j'ai plus vendu de disques où j'ai eu un
un désintérêt de la part du public ou
pas du tout je remplissais des salles et
tout âge j'ai arrêter aujourd'hui ça
vous choque pas quand vous entendez
stromae qui dit j'arrête j'en ai un
gérald j'en ai ras-le-bol
je m'arrête ça vous choque pas quand il
reviendra
on sait pas choquer comme surviendront
ouais mais sûrement mais mais c'est
peut-être à partir de l'andam vous étiez
vous a disparu trappe on ramène toujours
ça à une traversée du désert à quelque
chose de négatif de 2 d'horribles à
vivre alors que pas du tout je vais très
bien